hello and welcome once again to Android
design in action
I'm your host Roman Nurik hey guys my
baby's out of class and hi my name is
Nick butcher
and today we have an episode about the
visual design and specifically I guess
we'll talk about the specs or red lines
for the Cricut app that rado put
together with a Cricut app design that
rato put together and I think it was
last Friday's app clinic once we're done
talking about that we're gonna jump into
a couple of design details and
recommendations on how to incorporate
Maps specifically Google Maps into your
app we have a bunch of interesting fun
slides there and yeah should be fun so
with that let's get started with the
Cricut at visual design Nick you want to
take it away yeah absolutely so for
those of you who didn't catch the App
clinic last week reto meier looked
through his ideal kind of design both in
terms of screen design as well as
architecture so creating and up to date
kind of sports results app so if you've
missed it I encourage you to check it
out it's a really great episode and here
on screen we see what he put together
so while reto spent a lot of time
thinking about the functionality of the
application and I think he's done a
pretty good job he didn't and statute in
fact he stated he wasn't going to focus
very much on the visual design so were
you going to pick up where he left off
pass over the banner and and have a look
at some of the visuals that we can do
here so just quickly the app on the left
is a cricket score tracking application
it has a panel top for tracking kind of
in progress working on what's going on
now games and then it has a panel below
which gives you a summary of the
upcoming matches which are kind of
sorted by all kinds of intelligent
signals as to which they're going to be
relevant to the user I'm not going to
lay on a toothpick sorry Adam about the
ashes result because I just wouldn't be
sporting of me to just pile the shame on
to my poor Z colleagues so we'll skip
past that
so what we will look at though is some
of the steps that we've taken to kind of
address and some of the visuals and
we're gonna take it step by step and
build it build it up so one of the first
things I looked at is the action bar so
one of my favorite components one of the
key navigational components in the
Android platform and I'm not sure if it
as a conscious choice but reach I picked
this kind of an blue color to the action
bar and one of my problems is this is
one of the stock Android holo colors and
I find if an application kind of goes
with this kind of like stock kind of
blue it makes it feel almost two
stocking away it's almost like no kind
of attention has been paid to it or
you're just kind of using them out of
the box component so what I decide to do
is like what I'm going to think of
Cricut I kind of think of like green
fields with players wearing white and
then a red ball and that's kind of
palette I think to work with so we
instead reskin that using this kind of
grass green I'm going to call it as kind
of our strong single accent color which
we're going to extend throughout the app
later on and then went for a and
monochrome icon which works quite well
so again pick up on our white and green
and so you've got kind of a cricket bat
and like on that and one thing we've
done is we've actually themed the title
text as well there so picking up on the
weight at the iPhone we've used we've
gone for a slightly heavier heavier
weight so here we have robust or bold
condensed and a slightly larger font
size so again I pick up on the on the
icons weight as well as we went with the
metallic and theme there to kind of give
it some kind of emotion and as well as
adding some of the usual items you might
find in the action bar so retailer said
he's going to navigation bra so we added
the thrall affordance there and as well
as adding search and home so step one we
had a little look at the action bar and
showed it some visual love one of the
things that I really like about this is
specifically when you look at the the
way the icon is juxtaposed with the
title the weights of the of the glyphs
and the font are are actually
you know not really similar but they
balance well with the thickness of the
of the icon so it's not like the icon is
overpowering the tete the title text or
vice versa it's actually very nicely
balanced so I think that bold condensed
works really well here moving on okay
step two so what we picked an accent
color we then and took a look at the
rest of the pallet in the application so
we extended the accent color throughout
so you can see it in the the header and
in the kind of page indicator we picked
up how to same color and but also the
original use this kind of quite quite
stark contrasting palette so we had like
a near black and section to the top and
then a white section below very very
highly contrasting and it kind of felt
to me a little bit to visually
contrasting and as a side note you want
to be quite careful in your use of pure
white very very bland pure white colors
just uses the technology and most most
phones and tablets users have in their
hands have these very very bright
screens so using pure white can actually
be kind of overpowering so you want to
reserve pure white for something which
you want to draw attention to you want
to have some stark contrast not so much
for kind of a background panel so what
we've done here is we kind of muted the
color scheme down a little bit so we've
gone fit these kind of them off white
and some kind of gray back background
just to kind of make it a little easy on
the eye a little less contrasting yeah
perfect Morgan yeah so next we took a
little look at the metrics and so
there's a few things you can do to your
applications to really easily make it
easier to both scan and then to work out
you know what items are belong together
and which items are separate so we
applied the standard kind of 8 and 16
dip grid which we commonly talked about
here on a show and to this to this
screen here so you can see here with
discomfort we just moved some of the
kind of lines around change the margins
and the spacings just to line up to this
it's majorly a 16 dip grit and then for
any minor kind of
into listitem kind of spacing we've gone
4-h or sometimes even for dips
so basically we're using this kind of
system ribbon and it just makes it feel
much easier to kind of like work out
what belongs together and see how things
should be spaced out not really related
to the metrics if I also swapped I don't
want to talk about I want to swap out
the view and the view page indicated
here as well so instead of them I think
before we have four dots with one of
them cousin I said I've gone to this
kind of par with a kind of coven kind of
almost like a scroll bar it's a slightly
more androidy design like having these
angled you know flatter kind of lines
rather than these dots which is a bit of
a hangover from kind of the IRS design
guys and you'll see this view pager or
this pager indicator I guess in apps
like the launcher obviously you know
when you swipe between your different
home screens although it's a little hard
to see there as well as apps like Google
Currents X it keeps the assistant
whereas launcher kind of fades it out
which is kind of subtle and it's right
for a home screen but I think that's
something where you actually want in
together there's more content this is
kind of present design like works works
very well yeah one of the things I want
to point out as you mentioned you know
grouping the ability for whitespace and
margins to to communicate relationships
between elements and kind of group
things together this is something that
that Alex paperwork talks about a lot in
in a couple of his talks in Google i/o
this year and I think last year as well
but basically the I think it's the
gestalt principle for you know for
grouping you know placing items in close
proximity naturally implies a grouping
so it helps here I think to communicate
these are individual elements you almost
can imagine like what would happen if
you removed all the the list item
separators right would be the structure
still be a parent and I think in this
case it would given that there are ample
margins it also makes for a much better
reading experience as you're scrolling
down your I can naturally land on an
individual item and once you actually
see something interesting on an
individual item then you can kind of
spend one more time to explore it rather
than having to parse out which are the
individual items in your list
great cool and then the the last step
that we took on this on this screen here
if you then apply some different type of
graphical treatments and to really tease
out the information hierarchy so in the
previous design like though all the
information was there but was a little
bit overwhelming to try and understand
what was the most important and nothing
really jumped out to you you kind of
came across as kind of almost too dense
as blocks of text so what we've done
here is we've used things like color and
additionally different sizes and weight
of the different and text to kind of
really tease out what is the most
important so I think the first thing I
look at is you know the school obviously
jumps out up straight straight away at
you as well as the team names in the
summary section and then scaling down
the upcoming list it's very very easy to
quickly pass this list and find a game
you know you're going to look at it look
at this list and see all right that's
the game I'm looking for and then you
can like deep dive further down to find
subsequent information so by using these
different text sizes colors and weights
and it's it's really I think helps tease
out the information hierarchy so one of
the things we want didn't want to do is
introduce too much complexity so there
is actually only and two different font
size of three different font sizes if
you include the score on the screen here
so it's not too busy there's not too
much going on but by using these
different colors and weights we can
really establish the hierarchy yeah I
think that really makes a huge
difference and I think we've mentioned
this before on the show but I was
actually looking at the two screen sort
of from a distance because we've got a
TV here to view the slides and when you
take a step back you can really see what
the difference that it makes when you
look at it from that distance like you
can see the the titles very clearly as
opposed to the old screenshot where you
just sort of say these blur sections of
text which you can't really understand
or comprehend very well
one thing I want to pick up on is the
use of kind of like the ball cap style
which is fairly commonly used in Android
it's actually sometimes use for the less
important information so it might seem
kind of counter to counter intuitive to
when you might use capitals you might
think there's a shouting but quite
commonly in Android we'll use a smaller
and text lightest with a kind of a
lighter font color this full value
perhaps coupled with your cap style and
it really is this kind of like by lionel
strap liners like the detailed
information I think this works quite
well here for you know making this
information seem like it is secondary
information yep just to give rate of
some credit I will say that you know the
the amount of information I think was
accurate was it was correct right I mean
and I will say that I'll caveat that I
know nothing about cricket but one of
the things that you should also think
about in terms of typography and what to
put on your screen is you know are you
put are you showing too much at once are
you showing too little and if I will say
that I feel like Rado in the original
design was actually showing the the
right amount of detail the right amount
of information again caveat that I know
nothing about cricket but I think that
it's really you know once you decide
what to show and really kind of pick and
choose and again you're on mobile you
don't want to cloud the users you know
context with with too much stuff you
don't to cloud their vision with too
much unnecessary information but once
you decide what to what to show you have
to really think about how to show it how
to kind of portray the hierarchy and I
think that's where typography really can
really help yeah the one thing like that
that I wasn't quite sure about was I
think the second flag the second England
flag on the left screen here Kingdom
notes on the only one I think it denotes
though you keep me bowling next to the
number of overs Bowl and I found that
kind of repetition of the visual a
little bit kind of jarring kind of a
little bit I mean she just so I swap
that out for a red dot which is supposed
to look a bit like a cricket ball right
so I thought that clean of the visuals
and also made it feel a bit more
balanced Karen okay yeah I actually I
remember making some minor tweaks here
and I wasn't quite sure what was going
on again because I know nothing about
cricket
I guess it's another election no your
users know what you're designing before
you design it so
all right let's crack on so the other
thing we would this exercise I've been
cleaning up you know it's showing how
easy it is to perform a few tweaks on
the information in reach I've done the
hard work like Roman says the hard work
is deciding what to show on the screen
and how much information to show we just
kind of provided a little few visual
tweaks to make it easier to scan and
easier to conceive and then another
thing we're going to do this exercise is
just demonstrate how you would take such
a you know such a mark and then
communicate that design to a developer
so here's an example of them the kind of
technique we use in our applications
here and it's kind of like redlining
technique where we'll actually you know
overlay the document with these kind of
red boxes and annotations I guess it's
showing exactly what font sizing spacing
and going through and just really
documenting everything including there's
an example of like the touch highlight
you know the opacity the color and so
forth
so this is really kind of like the
interface the designer has with a
developer right this is information a
developer wants to know they want to
know there's no good just giving them a
PSD or something like that they want to
know things in dip sizes and can
absolutely colors and so on so they
don't have to go digging in to a PSD
files appliance information one of the
things that I find really useful is when
you're when you're creating a responsive
design or something where you're
targeting multiple devices rather than
using potentially I matter know if this
will actually work in practice but it's
definitely something that I've thought
about before rather than using like for
dip or eight dip or sixteen dip here you
could say like small or medium or large
and then have like a lookup table saying
you know on phone size devices small is
this size medium is this size larger
this dies and then on let's say
seven-inch devices or once you have 600
dips of of horizontal space let's say
you start bumping those up and having
something like a lookup table we're
basically like this is small this is
normal this is large and so on and so
forth that's actually really easy for
developers to then take and map into
Dimensions files so you can literally
just take that lookup table and create
you know xml files to specify the
dimensions and those in the
you could go and adjust the dimensions
as well things like the tech size like
I've specified here is own 18 SP but
that's kind of map store what we have is
this kind of text appearance medium is
this kind of standard text size and
that's 18 SP on some devices but it
could be larger on other devices you
know in the flash which were more likely
to hold forever away but it could
actually be at a larger value so rather
than specifying anything any number I
guess you could swap out for some kind
of look of value right yeah all right
let's let's carry on to the navigation
drawer yeah so we didn't redo the whole
application we just looked at this one
screen but I didn't want to kind of pick
up on saying on an application drawer so
and Rito's used it and they're kind of
like you know he's done a good
subdivision of the different sections
and but to me there was a couple
problems with it firstly like the
individual navigation kind of items felt
a little bit in substantial so we think
like that this is that your major
navigation within the application so I
wanted it to feel a little bit weightier
and and the other problem I felt was
there was no kind of an idea of
selection so if you currently currently
on one of those screens you know you
should go back to that yes this is where
you are in the application and so this
is what we did you know some very very
easy visual tweaks we just change the
screen so and the first thing we did is
we changed the line height of each item
and to pick up on the size of the action
bar so here on a phone size device is
going to be 48 dips but on a larger
device that can't might grow up to like
56 steps for example but yeah this
echoes that the height of the action bar
so it kind of falls into the natural
rhythm of the screen and echoing the
system components and we then kind of
like borrowed from the star we picked up
for the and the screen title and use
this kind of like bold italic it's not
the condensed version here just because
I didn't feel like you kind of sat quite
right and so this is just actually
Roboto medium italic yeah but yeah I
think these items can I feel a bit
weight yeah
and we didn't actually go through and
create glyphs or find glyphs for this
but I feel like having some kind of
iconography would also help with this
sense of place
yep and then we have a spec for the
navigation drawer you put together link
yeah exactly so I just want to call out
a few items here so this is how you
might expect this and
so one of the things we've done here is
we followed our guidelines that a
navigation drawer should be it's between
240 and 320 dips so we've we kind of
like call that out explicitly so it's
not going to grow too big and we've
called out things like the the drop
shadow to use like just to the right the
draw it has a very subtle kind of like
free dip drop shadow variable Center P
and pasty so you know just calling out
all this kind of documentation that your
developers can I'm gonna want to see and
you can see they're actually kind of
similar to how remember if you can zoom
in on the big square there over
countries icon and you know we specify
the kind of the icon frame area we've
got it 48 by 48 dip we've actually
specified there in brackets like you
should be the same height as the action
bar so like a developer's going to see
that oh right yeah ok so I can see and I
should kind of assign that to the same
height action bar so on a different
device it might be a different size yep
all right any parting thoughts for this
design no really I don't let you say I
think really good great job in the hard
work of actually working out the kind of
information design and we've just shown
a few easy techniques in order to kind
of communicate that better yeah I think
you know reto started with with basic
wireframes like you said the information
architecture and then the process of
taking that and creating you know medium
to high fidelity visual design Moxa's
you know it's it's fairly simple I think
that you really start with the grid you
then move on to things like typography
color and so on but you know really once
you have the wireframes I think it it
becomes a little pretty easy to put
together the visual design or not to not
to trivialize all the work we did Nick
but alright so let's move on to two maps
so Adam you take we've four Maps yeah so
let's talk about Google Maps Android the
API version 2
so hopefully this doesn't need too much
of an introduction it was released last
year with great fanfare as an upgrade to
the original version of maps or map view
it's a it's a great API
you know if you
an app that takes advantage of all that
needs to display content on a map it's
definitely something you should use for
those of you who aren't familiar with it
you know it's a very powerful API that
lets you sort of display these
vector-based map components in your
application and the advantage of that is
that well first of all there's technical
advantages to it but from a visual
perspective the user can actually pan
tilt rotate the camera as the user looks
at the map very easily and it's just a
really immersive interactive experience
and they can see 3d building silhouettes
which is actually really good for
providing extra context for you know if
you're looking for an apartment or
looking for pizza places or something
that's actually you know that extra bit
of context indigo it's a really neat
feature I think it only happens when you
zoom to a certain zoom level and in some
cities but yes it's really cool when you
see what's it I think one of my favorite
changes in maps v2 is that I think in
the Maps v1 there were some technical
limitations about how many maps you
could have in your application and so on
and so forth so if you had developers
pushing back about their designs about
where you can I can't include a map
that's no longer the case of v2 you can
have kind of as many map objects and
that's big or small and make them
animate and move as you like so don't
take that for an answer
yeah I think you're also referring to
map fragment there which literally using
that as sort of a portion of the screen
rather than taking up the entire screen
sir
yeah definitely great updates in the v2
version of the Maps API so in terms of
interacting with the map there's a few
sort of standard controls that come with
the API picture here you see the zoom
controls compass and my location those
are sort of fixed in various corners of
the map if you enable them the zoom
controls is sort of always in the bottom
right the compass is in the top left and
it's actually not always visible it's
only visible when the user rotates or
sort of moves the map away from the
default angle or rotation and then
there's my location button which is in
the top right corner normally and of
course these can all be toggled on and
off and you can also create your own UI
controls if you want as well these are
just the standard ones
and then there's also some standard
mapping gestures that can use zooming in
you know obviously pinch zoom is a is a
standard gesture for zooming and on the
map or zooming out scrolling or panning
just by touching the screen and dragging
tilting is using two fingers to drag up
and down rotate two fingers to rotate
around these are sort of pretty standard
things that you've probably already
experienced when using maps so in terms
of customizing the map there's two main
components that you can sort of
customize well there's a few others but
the main ones here are markers and info
windows so markers are the actual little
markers that drop down on the map to
indicate a location and info windows are
those little dialog boxes which pop up
normally when you touch one of those
markers so obviously the default ones
are kind of plain and boring you should
almost always customize these to fit you
up appropriately the info window is they
do support layouts but they're very
static so for the developers out there
you'll find that you can't actually make
some dynamic updates those views it
really just draws it once and then
you're sort of stuck with that until you
riad them again and I think we've got
some more information and well the one
thing I wanted to mention was touch
targets so when we were designing the
Google i/o app which you see pictured
here we're actually thinking oh can we
have an info window that has like a
primary target and then like a secondary
Seymour target and unfortunately the
current limitation is that no the entire
info window is a single touch target and
there's no real way to customize that so
there's no way to have like a like a
button to the top right or or like a
separate kind of section in that info
window that takes you all swear so just
plan for that and keep things simple it
does kind of help and help simplify the
interaction model for the map but it is
a current limitation this is a good
example in the
of customizing the info windows so you
can see here the Android track is
selected and we've got the sort of nice
green highlight faded there with the
little Android icon in the top right and
just for the developers in the audience
what basically happens is you can
provide your own layout but what the map
component will do is it'll take a
snapshot of that layout it'll actually
draw it lay it out and so on it'll take
a snapshot and then use that that bitmap
snapshot to render the info window so
it's not actually like a textview and
another texture and so on it's really
just like a snapshot it's an imbecilic
old roll at the end of the output is it
just displays exactly yeah you want to
talk a bit about yeah so some a couple
of you know ideas for marker visual
design there's really two types of
markers that you can have and I guess
you can you can use whatever shapes you
want you know if you have let's say a
person on a map obviously if I want to
use their avatar in there somewhere and
then that'll guide some of the shapes
but if it's just a very basic marker
that indicates something a couple of I
guess a couple of suggestions the first
is to try to use your brand accent color
so just as you would use your accent
color and the action bar or for like
list section headers or you know subtle
accents throughout definitely keep using
that here in your monitor images and I
think that will we'll probably able to
share a PSD kind of template for this
kind of thing at some point but here's
an example from the i/o app we actually
didn't use this one on the right here
but we did use this where basically the
marker ends up just being white since we
know the background is colored and then
we use the standard Google i/o purple or
blue to red gradient as as one of the
items within the marker image so it
helps to kind of further that that
message of brand consistency throughout
the app another thing I wanted to
mention is around density so if you have
a lot of markers this is one of the
things that I pet peeves I guess when
you open up like a let's say a real
estate search app or a pizza search or
whatever and there's like you know
hundreds of results and all you see are
just these these
yeah sea of markers it's not that useful
right you can no longer see the map you
kind of lose the whole point of having a
map there it's just kind of like a whole
bunch of you know people standing in a
crowd and you can't really make out any
one of them so for those cases you may
want to use a smaller marker and the
point here is not to actually have a
smaller touch target the touch target
should still really be kind of the same
size maybe a little smaller you know
like this entire or I guess all around
this one for example this marker should
be like a touch region that touching
that you know actually triggers it but
the idea here is that you know it
doesn't really matter if you
accidentally click the wrong one what
you what the user would do is be able to
zoom in to see more information about
that area and once the markers these
smaller markers are well separated out
then there will be kind of no ambiguity
in terms of which one you clicked so the
idea is you know use smaller markers
purely for the purpose of seeing the map
underneath because like we said before
actually like what was said in one of
the slides there was the map is our
Chanel later on the map is the UI right
like the whole context the whole
interface for the user is the map it's
the geographic context so you don't want
to obscure that with too many markers
and speaking of that if you you know the
maps not going to provide the clustering
kind of algorithm for you because we
leave that to you you probably know more
about the information and how to cluster
yourself but you want to have an example
of how we do clustering there's a great
and blog post called too many markers
and from the Google Maps team describing
how we do clustering so the developers
out there who want to implement that at
Google for too many markers cool all
right all right moving on
so changing the view as I mentioned
before you've got a lot of control
around how the sort of user is viewing
the perspective that it uses viewing the
map basically the camera angle the users
viewing the map on and actually the Maps
API makes it really really easy to
animate the camera between locations you
know basically animate the location zoom
bearing and tilt all these different
things and actually it does it by just
sending an extra flag it will animate
between two locations and this is really
useful for sort of giving user a sort of
way of illustrating that the the
difference between two locations so for
example if you're viewing something in
New York you want to jump across the
London the map will very quickly zoom
out swing across the London and sort of
give you this very easy mental spatial
idea that you've moved a very long
distance across the map and I guess one
point to mention that is is that you
shouldn't you don't need to always pan
the map if there's tons of different
infinitives around so that will mean
that the touch targets where the users
trying to touch the map will keep
shifting from underneath them so in
those particular cases you may want to
sort of minimize the amount that the map
moves around but in most other cases it
can be useful to show these animations
between locations yeah and I think
there's I think with the API there's no
automatic panning behavior so you can
definitely customize you know what
happens when you when you touch
something but really you know that point
I can't mention it enough it's it's the
you know one of my other pet peeves I'd
say is when you touch like a marker
that's kind of like just off-center and
then it resent there's the whole thing
and like everything else shifts around
underneath you and I mean obviously the
animation helps maintain that context
but it would still just be much better
if you just kind of kept things in place
only moving the the map as much as you
need just to show the content yes if you
touch like so if you tap the marker like
maybe the edge of the screen then you
may want to pen
but if as roman saying it's just
off-center it may not make sense yeah
alright let's let's move through since
we're running okay the most important
slides will have no time yeah so a
full-screen map or a large map the
reason why I say large map here is just
because if you're on a larger screen
device it may not actually be a full
screen map and may sort of taking up the
majority of the screen but not all the
screens so in this particular case the
map is really the interface here you
should really allow you know panning
tilting zooming rotating not allowing
those it's kind of unexpected to the
user they're sort of be expecting to be
able to do all of those things and of
course you should be minimizing UI
distraction now one thing that we've
recommended in the past is using the
action about overlay mode so adding some
transparency there to the action bar and
this is actually from one of our first
episodes of Android design in action
that we did a very long back now I will
note that it's it's a great thing that
you can enable if possible there is a I
guess a minor issue with it from a
technical aspect perspective in that the
Maps API will actually show the UI
controls underneath the action bar
potentially because it doesn't actually
relay out those UI controls in some
cases when you engage the overlay mode
so it's it's maybe not appropriate at
the moment for all applications
maybe if using custom UI controls it
could work but definitely if you can
enable it would be it's a really neat
feature to sort of make the map feel
more immersive all right yeah let's fly
through yeah okay so embedded map so now
the map is not it's not full screen
anymore and and what's written here the
map is really the context here so it's
just trying to give some context around
the information on the rest of the
screen in this case you should really be
removing or minimizing the UI
controllers you know you don't really
need to have the zoom buttons the users
probably not going to be doing two
fingered gestures in that time a little
space
this is an example from Foursquare by
the way and the nice thing that force
could actually does here is if you tap
on the map a single press it actually
expands the map out to the full screen
and sort of switches back to that full
screen map mode that I was talking about
before and then the last thing is that
there is a sort of you could potentially
switch using static Maps if you're using
embedded maps so not really having any
interactional or removing some of that
dynamic feel from the maps until you tap
on it and maybe be taken to a full
screen full screen map anything else so
guys I know III really know I think I
think you covered it pretty well though
sir yeah I would say so yeah also take a
look at it they're kind of the updates
to Google Maps applications I think
that's a phenomenal job of doing some of
the things Roman was talking about like
keeping the kind of interface stable but
having easy interaction to kind of move
between different pins and stuff so I
think that's a great example as well yep
all right design news and let's try to
do this in like a minute
first if you are in the Bay Area San
Francisco mountain do whatever there's
an Android designers meeting coming up a
meet-up coming up
check out this URL here to meet up comm
and join I think the first event is
happening next week August 6 now if
everyone seducing Stiller in London then
ping Meeks I wouldn't mind starting some
others yes oh and we have similar New
York Android designers meetup I don't
think we have the next one planned yet
but sometime in August hopefully so
alright next so one thing I really
wanted to point out is that we've been
posting a lot of pro tips on the ANT+
Android developers Google+ page we have
a bunch of you know Android development
pro tips but also a bunch of Android
design pro tips so this one here
specifically about the new Nexus 7 that
was that was launched last week
and specifically some design details
they're basically long story short you
have already designed for the new Nexus
7 there's no extra work to do you know
it's a it's a basically a the same dip
resolution as the old Nexus 7 just with
a higher density so everything should
just work but yeah and oh my god it's
beautiful everything so shop yes it is
it is a gorgeous screen and lastly
one of the things that was new and
Android 4.3 is this new kind of optical
bounce feature so basically if before
you know your nine-patches had extra
spacing around there to account for
things like drop shadows and glows and
such and that caused your UI elements to
not really visually line up and curl
greshnev did a fabulous blog post about
this specific problem and how they
addressed this in the Google Play Store
but if you were having this problem and
you want to address it as of Android 4.3
there's a new feature called kind of
optical bounds in nine patches so
basically in your nine patches you have
these extra red markings to indicate
that this should be the kind of negative
margins that you should shift the UI
element to so that the left visual
visual edge or the left
optical edge aligns with other items in
that along that line along that edge so
as new in Android 4.3 you kind of go
from you know kind of a sloppy layout
here on the left to something a little
more clean and well aligned and the
right and pretty easy to do
yeah I think that's all the time we have
today so thank you everybody for for
tuning in I think I don't know what
we're doing next week or when our next
show will be but see you soon I'm your
host Roman Nurik see you guys bye nigga
adios folks